(upbeat music)
Welcome back.
I'm outside the CBS broadcast center on
the busy streets of New York city,
and it's all to celebrate our next guest.
Stephanie Stanky.
A mechanic who at 29 joined a small list
of women who own automotive repair shops.
She's our latest wildflower
and empowering other women to learn more about cars,
really revs my engine.
Stephanie is joining us now.
Hi, Stephanie, how are you?
I'm doing so well.
Thank you so much for having me.
I really admire you.
How are you?
I feel the exact same way about you, Stephanie.
You've made it your mission to empower other women
to learn more about cars.
Will you explain?
Absolutely.
So it's gonna struggle working in this fields.
It's something that I absolutely love doing.
It's my passion.
But throughout the years, I've had to deal
with lot of struggles with the things people have said
with the things people had done
with the lower pay that's been offered.
And, I can only imagine that's what consumers feel like to
especially women that want to take the vehicles in.
So that's something that we're working
towards to try to create a better environment
for women that do wanna work in this field,
especially going forward.
And I've had to create my own opportunities to do that.
Wow.
I really respect what you just said.
And it makes all the sense in the world.
And I thank you for bringing that out
into the spotlight,
because I love when women do what men do.
I love when men do what women do.
It should all be equal opportunity
and the pay should be equal as well.
Now I feel like I'm a bad cliche, Stephanie
because I know if I broke
down on the side of the road,
I wouldn't know who to call.
I would feel helpless.
And most importantly, I would be scared.
And the best way to conquer fear is to fix it,
figure it out and learn.
So I'm really excited about not only shining a light
on the important things that you're doing,
but learning how to empower myself,
because it is all about rescuing yourself,
whether you're a man or a woman.
So show me how to do this.
So that I can know what to do in this situation.
Absolutely the best way to feel comfortable
and confident when you have your own car is just
to know kinda how to do some of those basics yourself.
So today I'm gonna show you how to jumpstart a battery
by using a portable jump pack.
So if you ever get stuck on the side of the road
you don't have to rely on strangers to do that.
You don't have to hope that whoever stops,
you don't have to worry about who they are as a person.
You can find them at any local parts store.
You can find them online
portable jump packs come with a variety of features.
But they're usually within like the 80 to $150 range
that you can find a really good one that you can leave
in your car.
So the thing that we're gonna do,
we're just gonna actually identify on the car
what you wanna be looking for first.
So to get started
you're gonna want to identify which one is your positive
and which one is your negative?
So usually the positive has a red cable.
A red cover.
All right.
That's pretty clear.
Plus, red positive.
Got it.
All right.
Thank you.
So you want to make sure you watch
for any jewelry, any,
anything that you could have dangling,
you don't want anything crossing first.
So you make sure that
you've got everything out of your workspace.
So we want to look for the red clip first.
You're gonna always connect the positive first.
Okay. So I've got it on there.
So then you're gonna wanna connect black cable
and make sure that you have a solid connection on there
that they're not flapping around you,
they're not falling over.
You just wanna clamp it on pretty easy.
So then with the jump pack that we have
you're gonna wanna go ahead and turn that on.
There's this, this power button right there.
You wanna make sure to turn that on.
We'll down for just a second there when it's charged.
Okay. So what's next?
Do I finally go to start the dead vehicle?
You're gonna go ahead and start your vehicle first.
Okay.
So I'm gonna start it.
Are you ready?
(engine starting)
(people applauding)
It's started, Stephanie
Perfect.
So you just wanna let it run for a minute?
Just so the alternator can keep recharging your battery
and then once you're ready to come back up front.
Okay.
So how long do I let it run for?
Usually you'll just let it run about two to five minutes
depending if it is a real quick jumpstart.
You really gotta get out of there.
I mean, you do want to make sure once you do start at you
you do let it run after that and drive it.
You don't just shut it right back off right away.
You wanna let it recharge a bit.
Before you drive you do wanna take it back off.
So you wanna let it run for,
maybe that five minute mark first.
And then we're gonna go right ahead and turn it back off.
Okay.
I mean, it was like simple logic.
Turn off the thing that's sending electric current.
Ah, okay.
Oh, that was just me.
(people laughing)
Nothing happened.
Okay.
So when you do take it off
you actually wanna start by taking off
your negative cable first.
But you don't want
I did.
You did?
Yes, I did.
Okay. But that's important.
Start by taking the negative cable off first.
So get rid of the bad vibe.
Take off the negative,
like hone in on the positive, then remove that second.
Then remove it.
And isn't it funny that you can conquer your fear just
by getting on top of it and figuring it out.
Here is the solve
you are my hero.
And I'm wondering, Stephanie
I also don't know how to change a tire
on the side of the road.
Would you be willing to come back
on the show and teach me how to do that?
I would love to do that.
I would be so happy to teach you that.
Okay. Me too.
I literally was like, Oh, what's more important.
The battery or the tire.
How that we do both and help everybody.
Well do them both
Exactly. All right.
We're gonna put these instructions
on TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com
and thank you, Stephanie.
Thank you for empowering me to rescue myself.
(upbeat music)